[Musique]
g
marité a dit l'insee coeur bonjour merci
d'être présente sur le plateau de tv
soixante dix huit pour ce vip que l'on
va entièrement vous consacrez vous êtes
c'est notre chance c'est heavy noise
vous avez vécu très longtemps pas loin
d'ici
vous revenez régulièrement je crois
savoir que vos enfants ont appris à
faire du vélo dans le parc du château
absolument ils se souviennent bien vous
avez des souvenirs et vous avez sorti un
livre qui s'appelle la voie du feng shui
oui voila je le montre mais en même
temps voilà chevaucher le temps
apprivoisé laisse pas assez prendre sa
place tout un programme on le voit à
l'écran
voilà la belle couverture la jolie
couverture est donc tout un programme
j'aimerais savoir comment vous
définissez votre métier a déjà fait un
petit peu il serait il serait facile de
s'arrêter simplement au terme de sphinx
ou et qui est dans le titre
or met pas que maître févry non en fait
la technique du feng shui et fait partie
d'une palette d'art de discipline qui
sont en fait au service de la vitalité
de l'individu ce jeu là en chine mais
ont elles sont aussi présentes en
occident l'acupuncture la le tchi kong
le tai-chi ce sont des arts parallèle à
ce que je fais la différence dans ma
pratique c'est au lieu de travailler sur
le corps de la personne c'est d'utiliser
d'analysé et de m'appuyer sur l'espace
dans la quête dans lequel la personne
vit l'espace gérer spatiaux ravi mais le
lieu il ya un volet spatiale et il ya un
volet temporel parce que dans cette
culture classique chinoise l'objectif
est de minimiser la perte de force
l'idée étant que la santé sera d'autant
plus renforcée que la personne ne
s'épuise pas et donc moi je je
représente des techniques qui vont
s'appuyer sur l'espace et sur le temps
choisir le bon lieu le bon moment pour
booster ce que nous cherchons à faire
d'accor et pour avoir le maximum
d'énergie et de vitalité
on nous oui le le
le ca fait partie en fait d art au
service du décuplement des forces
personnelles d'accord donc l'acupuncture
quand vous disiez en fait aussi partie
donc si j'ai bien compris il ya deux
volets dont danse et art chinois ont dit
à chênois on peut y aller ou disciplines
pratiquées qu'asiatique de voilà donc
deux volets le côté guérison quand il ya
un souci donc l'acupuncture et d'autres
shows la pharmacopée
voilà exactement et vous vous appartenez
au volley entre guillemets prévention
absolument c'est à dire que quand on lit
votre livre on comprend que il ya plein
de choses qui nous apporte soit de
l'énergie positive et ça il faut
cultiver et ils en ont identifié déjà et
le cultiver après et a contrario vous
avez il ya aussi plein de choses qui
malheureusement nous font baisser notre
énergie
donc notre vitalité donc peuvent nuire
aussi quelque part à la santé puisque
tous ses global est qu'il faut aussi
tenir ça à l'oeil et en avoir conscience
et et de la même manière d'ailleurs que
en acupuncture traditionnellement on
allait voir le médecin quand on était
encore en bonne santé de manière à
éviter un souci donc là le chant est un
petit peu plus ouverts c'est
d'identifier pour une personne pour une
famille les lieux les environnements et
les moments qui sont les plus en phase
avec ce qui renforce leur vitalité
personnel parce que pour les chinois
l'important c'est d'avoir la santé et
vont du le sida et moi aussi d'ailleurs
parce que celui de santé bien sûr mais
c'est aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le nouvel
an chinois
le nouvel an chinois donc un renouveau
énergétique dans un système de pensée
qui considère que les années ne sont pas
neutres
les années ne sont pas que des numéros
pour nous occidentaux on passe de
l'année 2018 année digne 2019 on a un
nouvel an tous les ans le 1er janvier
qui nous amène à nous faire des
promesses contient pas souvent parce que
le temps pour nous est neutre
or dans ce dans cette pensée chinoise
classique
chaque année apporte une qualité
énergétique particulière
donc plus alors c'est frustrant pour
nous parce que si l'année et apporte une
qualité particulière si elle n'est pas
neutre je vais avoir à composer avec une
force extérieure à moi qui peut être
soit certaines années facilite en
potentialisant trou certaines années
ralentissant oui ne pas aller forcément
avec le projet qu'on a envie de faire
aboutir
et alors pardon le sous titre du livre
chevaucher le temps parce que le temps
est comparée à une force et ce mode de
pensée est aussi très comment dire
image et donc on va se le temps est une
force
on va chevaucher le dragon du temps plus
je suis en phase plus je fais les choses
au bon moment plus je le plus je suis
porté par une énergie temporel ça
facilite sa facilité donc il ya l'idée
de se glisser dans des courants
extérieurs à nous en les apprivoise en
les reconnaissant et que faire alors il
ya bien sûr il ya une technique qui est
derrière on a une technique hilaire qui
va vous dire tel - ou tel jour dans par
exemple tout le travail que je fais en
accompagnement de traitement de
l'infertilité
si vous accompagner des pistes et puis
aussi par rapport à des équipes en
traitement de l'infertilité médicale
médical on pourrait dire que à partir du
moment où on peut stimuler l'ovulation
d'une d'une femme
pourquoi faire une tentative en juillet
ou en août ou en juillet ou en juin
quelle est la différence dans ses
lectures il nous avons une possibilité
de dire tel mois et plus en phase avec
l'énergie de la procréation pour cette
femme tel projet par rapport à la dette
de notation et en l'absence d'un
praticien en l'absence de quelqu'un qui
a la technique il est important nous
avons nous mêmes une boussole interne
c'est ce que vous dites au début de
votre livre retrouvons notre boussole
interne parce que on l'a encore faut-il
l'identifier l'écouté et lui accorder
l'importance qu'elle mérite à cette
boussole et et boussens l'atteinte
qu'est ce qu'elle nous dit elle nous dit
là tu commences à être en perte de force
ou la ce lieu cette personne cette
activité te donne envie de te lever le
matin
privilège là mais la société telle
qu'elle est faite nous nous nous impose
tellement de contraintes nous mon
travail il cherche à accompagner la
personne pour qu'elle soit vraiment à sa
place et sa place c'est pas la place que
la société l'éducation ou les habitudes
donne c'est ce qui nous met en
respiration c'est ce qui nous nous ce
qui booste en fait nos forces et je suis
souvent surprise de voir à quel point
nous n'écoutons pas ce début de mal de
dos qui nous dit quelque chose où cette
fatigue certains jours dans certains
lieux qui finalement sont des signes
oui dit il convient d'écouter bien sûr
après il ya aussi les signes plus
concrets
il ya l'exemple de des choses que tout
le monde peut appliquer sans votre aide
grâce à ce livre un paillasson moche
pourri qui nous qui nous donne cette
sensation mots jetés des quartz chez soi
on l'enlève on en achète un c'est parce
que ça coûte
alors oui tous ces choses-là aussi à qui
nous font descendre notre énergie et
qu'on oublie de prendre en compte et
finalement elle s'accumule petit à petit
c'est l'effet du cumul qui est
problématique parce qu'on pourrait dire
on pourrait vraiment je le taquine un
point de taquiner sur l'importance que
j'apprends que j'attache au seuil
la manière dont on transition de
l'extérieur ce qu'ils appellent le
macrocosme extérieur dans la maison
microcosme intérieur qu'est la maison
donc la porte est un lieu de passage de
transition et l'on souhaite que la le
que l'on soit accueilli le paillasson
les face à sion agréable le paillasson
n'est pas simplement un endroit
pour nettoyer ses chaussures c'est un un
point d'atterrissage d'une énergie
extérieur qui va s'engouffrer avec vous
chez vous d'accord mais sans aller si
loin pardon je suis raide mais d'arriver
devant chez soi et de voir un joli
paillasson propre et 9 et bien ça donne
un très bon ça donne un hangar d'entrée
comme de trouver un bouquet de fleurs
dans l'entrée de sa alors vous vous êtes
un peu aussi vous donner une vision plus
globale du feng-shui parce que vous vous
avez un peu décoder le feng shui à la
chinoise à l'occe à l'orientale pour le
mettre à l'eau à l'occidentale voilà je
viens vous n'êtes pas à nous dire mettez
une petite fontaine métal je suis contre
les grigris je veux corriger absolument
et je pense que d'abord c'est technique
elle a été formalisée en chine mais elle
est universelle
la prise en compte du lieu comme cocon
ou comme enveloppe accompagnant notre
développement et notre chemin de vie
c'est une à porter de d'énergie positive
et de compagnons d'allier tête la maison
doit être être un allié bienveillant
elle peut l'être alors qu'elles
voudraient mieux elle peut la mi mai
dans un certain nombre de cas pareil
dans certain nombre de cas le la maison
nous prend de l'énergie plus parce
qu'elle nous en donne oui alors ça va
pas et ben c'est ça peut aller pendant
un certain temps puis reprenez mais vous
avez un exemple je vous coupe le paradis
désolé mais il ya un exemple qui est
génial c'est dans votre lit parce qu'il
ya y allait pas mal de cas concrets
aussi qui permettent de bien comprendre
les cas concrets de ce discours c'est
important et les 22m dans cet exemple de
l'architecte qui construit la maison de
ses rêves et qui vous appelle au secours
en disant mais je ne trouve pas ma place
dans cette maison je me sens mal c'est
complètement fou oui et la solution des
thèmes mais la solution n'était pas si
compliqué que ça là parce qu'on fait là
on était dans le cas d'une maison
extrêmement lumineuse poreuse
on dirait digue est pas une mûre pour
s'appuyer pas de murs pour sa part il ya
pas de refuge donc cette maison elle
était géniale pour être en mouvement
tout le temps où ça aurait été un lieu
favorable à une activité de type
professionnel
c'était sa maison privée dans laquelle
ils n'arrivaient pas à trouver sa place
voilà est ce que vous dites aussi très
bien c'est qu'aujourd'hui donc on a des
preuves d' espaces on habite des maisons
des appartements de plus en plus petit
mais qu'il suffit des choses qui nous
paraissent complètement anodine un sim
pour remettre les choses à leur place
c'est à dire que vous vous dites qu on
mélange tout on travaille dans la
cuisine on dort dans le salon où on
travaille aussi faim alors alors là il
ya aussi un autre lien qu'on n'a pas
vraiment si tu essaies tu sais que mon
travail vise en fait bien sûr au
déploiement à la préservation des forces
au déploiement des forces de la personne
mais aussi à l'encrage et donc si penser
aux arts martiaux qu'un le la force de
frappe en arts martiaux va être autant
la qualité du geste que la la la la
capacité de la personne à être bien
ancrée concentrer tout à son affaire qui
est soit de la défense ou l'attaqué
or cette cette métaphore cette analogie
elle est appliquée également dans nos
espaces plus l'espace et mélanger
ailleurs que plus on dort pas dans la
cuisine mais plus on travaille dans la
cuisine plus on a ces dossiers de
divorce cela n'était de la tête de l'ina
la craie tout en bas il a des choses
edel que le on a le plus de temps marie
pierre oui c'est qu'on est on perd en
concentration on perd en concentration
voilà bon vois ce que je j'encourage
tout le monde à lire ce livre c'est le
lien qu'il faut lire parce qu'on apprend
plein de choses on peut même le lieu
plusieurs fois parce que c'est très
riche et on peut commencer par la fin on
peut commencer par où on veut oui j'ai
justement le sens et aussi on attend le
prochain livre avec impatience je crois
me léon il est il est en cours et il est
en route et là on est
vraiment sur la mise en application de
12 clé extrêmement précises nous
permettant de nous réapproprier
d'une certaine manière notre être alors
pour nous en parler vous reviendrez dans
un an peut-être un va ça que je peux
voilà ben j'avais là les merdes bonne
année le printemps démarre aujourd'hui
et puis à quoi vous allez donner une
conférence sur l'année à venir à elle à
la maison de la chimie comme depuis 20
ans vous le faites et si je pouvais
souhaiter athlé vaut toutes vos idées
vos auditeurs téléspectateurs mais parce
que penser que deux de ceux d'éviter le
plus possible des petits compromis avec
leur santé d'accord en identifiant bien
chez eux
l'endroit ça ne peut être qu'un fauteuil
qu'un coussin ou vraiment ils sont bien
trouver votre place comme un chat
occuper la marée perd un gros merci
merci pour ces soins merci d'être venu
et a très vite j'espère un bon été
passionnant très bonne année en var
[Musique]